la más cruenta imagen de la batalla
entre los militares rusos y las fuerzas
ucranianas por el control de las
inmediaciones de la capital de ucrania
kiev las autoridades ucranianas estiman
que más de 300 civiles han sido
asesinados
muchos murieron por las minas rusas el
fuego de artillería mucha gente fue
abatida por los rusos dispararon a niñas
y mujeres luego pasaron por encima con
los tanques de expresión los combates se
recrudecieron el miércoles dejando una
ciudad fantasma con el 50% de las
infraestructuras completamente
destruidas irvine el escudo protector de
la capital está ahora bajo el control
del ejército ucraniano
el enemigo carne de cañón honestamente
todos los cadáveres son solo niños
tirados por ahí son como carne de cañón
que fue enviada aquí
sin embargo las autoridades ucranianas
señalaron que el territorio continúa
sufriendo bombardeos desde ciudades
vecinas controladas por moscú yo te cos
inc
hay otras palabras sobre la supuesta
retirada de las tropas rusas de que
isern y hips sobre la supuesta reducción
de la actividad de los ocupantes en
estas direcciones sabemos que no se
trata de una retirada sino de los
resultados del retroceso del trabajo de
nuestros defensores
de las tropas y brigadistas ucranianos
han logrado repeler el asalto del
ejército ruso las grandes urbes del país
resistiendo desde hace más de un mes los
bombardeos y la artillería del kremlin
mientras en las calles los socorristas
buscan un atisbo de vida entre las
ruinas